سؤال جديد في هذه الازمه هل دفعت حده
المعارك في اوكرانيا موسكو الى الاستعانه
بالايدي الناعمه تهمه ثقيله وجهتها صحيفه
البريطانيه الى روسيا بتوظيف النساء بشكل
مباشر في الحرب في اوكرانيا الصحيفه
البريطانيه ذكرت ان روسيا ترسل النساء
المدانات بتهم في السجون الروسيه الى
ساحات القتال في شرق اوكرانيا
التهمه لم توجه فقط من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني تقول صحيفه
بل ايضا من طرف منظمه خلف القضوان الروسيه
التي تدافع عن حقوق السجناء في روسيا
وبهذا الخصوص قالت رئيسه المنظمه اولغا
رومانوفا ان موسكو بدات في تجديد السجينات
نهايه العام الماضي وكان الجيش الاوكراني
قد ذكر في شهر فبراير الماضي من روسيا
اخرجت 50 مدانه من سجن في منطقه دوناتسك
التي تسيطر عليها موسكو وارسلته الى روسيا
للتدريب العسكري وفي سياق متصل اشاره
الصحيفه البريطانيه الا انه في ديسمبر
الماضي قال رئيس مجموعه بانجلا ريافيني ان
مجموعه من السجينات طلبنا ارسال هنا الى
اوكرانيا كممرضات او للعمل في مجال
الاتصالات العسكريه واضاف انه يجري العمل
على ذلك